one of the funniest things i ever i saw
on uh one of y'all's rule zero podcast
when somebody started talking about dick
pics and i'm like sterling cooper's like
i don't even have dick pics i'm like i'm
like that's the guy's job yeah so so
what's the rule with uh dick pics then
like you know how do you guys handle
that never do it what do you do if a
chick says says you know send me a
picture of your i've gotten a lot of
requests
awesome so i don't care
yeah
it's uh
and on the internet you guys can go
search
apex mindset dick pics probably find it
not really okay not really
as long as it's detached from us your
trolls are gonna go looking forward
they're like oh boy if i'm already
but if i'm involved with somebody my my
rule is this they get they see it first
then
okay like this i want to see in person
before
pics lots of requests whatever things
like that sure
you know
have edited girls i don't care and if i
get exposed this is what it looks like
it's only going to increase my female
followers i don't i don't give a
i'm going to work off of that about what
i'm supporting doesn't matter to me but
i don't want to use this as a measure
or to try to get the girl i think that's
a bit weak and that actually comes from
a deficiency
in the guy
fearing rejection so hear me out on this
it's like guys are so weak now but they
want acceptance
for what their junk is
before they're in front of her and they
actually show that show the goods right
they want the girl to go
wow
that's an amazing penis miscarriage
a lot of times if they ask i'd say it's
a red flag if the chick asked for it
you're not going to get anymore
because
for sure they're looking for attention
or it's it's it's not a joke there's
like a undercover like loki like gay guy
maybe posing as a girl because they yeah
i've come up in mexico that happens a
lot you should you should definitely not
be you can sense them you you know who
they are yeah you should not be sending
pictures of your junk like especially if
you're somebody of
your name is googlable and your face
isn't attached to the picture they're
not going to know what's yours but i
wouldn't send them the like guys send
them to girls as if they're going to
entice them with their anatomy to like
yeah very ridiculous and weak way of
handling things and that happens all the
time it's not recommended
you